sur votre iPhone si vous voulez savoir
quelle application vous espionne quelle
application a accès à vos données
extrêmement chaudes que ce soit vos
contacts votre localisation voici
comment faire vous venez ici dans
général vous descendez dans
confidentialité et sécurité et vous
allez tout en bas dans rapport de
confidentialité des apps vous saurez ici
quelle application aura accès à vos
données et à vos capteurs comme ça vous
pouvez venir supprimer des accès si vous
ne le souhaitez pas et vous avez plein
d'autres informations super
intéressantes sur votre confidentialité
je vous invite vraiment à venir acheter
un coup d'œil comme ça vous maîtriserez
la confidentialité des applications sur
votre iPhone